ce qui a justifié une partie de notre
mobilisation aussi sur le programme de
prévention de la participation des
jeunes au trafic de stupéfiant c'est le
recours de ces groupes criminels à des
petites mains de plus en plus jeunes
souvent 11 ans 12 ans 13 ans plus
seulement issu des quartiers dans
lesquels ils habitent dans lesquels se
fait se fait le trafic pardon mais qui
qui sont cherchés grâce à une sorte de
marché national du deal parfois dans des
zones qui sont des zones rurales
distante de plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres et qui sont recrutés par les
réseaux criminels pour faire un
travail sur les points de Deal par
exemple voilà un peu ce panorama je je
le résumerai en peut-être en en deux
mots donc à l'échelle française
peut-être une dynamique de l'offre une
structuration des réseaux criminels qui
évolue
particulièrement ce recrutement chez les
jeunes ne peut pas être totalement non
plus disconnecté si j'ose dire pardon de
ce mot d'un certain nombre de mots qui
traversent la société et la jeunesse en
particulier des questions qui sont
éminemment d'actualité au travers de
question éducative du sentiment
d'impunité forme d'individualisme de
recherche
de de d'argent qu'on do dépenser
immédiatement c'est vraiment très
frappant aujourd'hui quand on regarde
les plus jeunes participant au trafic et
l'extension des réseaux se fait un peu
sur le GR sur le dos de de ces plus
jeunes